so first moral of the story i want to
talk about that song first
that song is so devastating like what
was the inspiration behind that song
oh that's a that's a heavy word to use i
like that no one's done that anyone said
that it is
dating it's a compliment devastating i
love it
um well i mean it was it came of my
my real life sort of past and
experience my last relationship which
happened to be
a marriage so there's a like a whole
lot that goes on there when you decide
to break up with your husband
um it's kind of a lot but um
yeah that's probably why i think it it
is truly so vulnerable and devastating
as you use the word
um because it is it is really honest
um is it hard to write about stuff like
that like
that personal it's becoming
easier i've um is that good or bad
i know for real
um i don't know you know i think that
i've
i've done a lot of work around you know
sometimes as artists we can like
we attach all of our sort of self-worth
in
our art so when you're super vulnerable
with your lyrics and just lay it all out
there
if your self-worth is attached to it and
people hate it
they're you're i mean you're you're done
you know
i mean in my case i got lucky and people
loved it
um but still there's like a level of
detachment um
that regardless of like the love or hate
like i know
who i am aside from it i think that
makes a little bit easier
yeah and that was kind of rambly i don't
know if that made it well that made
sense that made sense
yeah and this song has had such a life
like when you found out whoever
came about that was going to be in to
all the boys too like obviously you know
it's going to be exposed to a huge
audience right like what was it like
finding that out well i
i knew it was going to be a huge
audience but i didn't think
like songs get placed in movies all the
time
and don't blow up
you know i i didn't expect what happened
um to happen i knew it was a really cool
like pivotal
um scene of the movie um and they told
us
this the music supervisors told me that
it was going to be a part where she lip
sang my
my lyrics and i was like well that's so
that's so cool i can't even imagine
anyone else singing
a song so it'd be cool to watch that a
little bit less than a year later
i watched the movie and whoa
this is insane and it just kept going on
usually like a song sync will end in
like
you'll get 15 20 seconds the song was
like it played like a minute and a half
of this
in the movie and i was like this might
actually be
this might actually be a big deal
it was yeah yeah that exploded and then
of course you do a new version
with some guy named not horn
[Laughter]
some guy how did that come about
oh my gosh i love now so much so cool
i'm such a fan i'm a fan
first so to have a song with him it's
like oh
cool i don't care if it's not cool to
think it's
cool right i just i'm such a i'm such a
fan
um so i have a really good friend of
mine
works she's the senior vice president of
a r at capital records
um and she was actually my publisher at
cobalt before
and then she left us because she had to
go be famous at capitol records and i
was like no don't leave me
and sure enough the very first thing she
did when she got to
her new position was introduce me to
niall um and niall had heard the song
and loved the song and
um put us in touch and we were on a
phone call
i mean within a couple days of her intro
we were on a phone call and um we're
facetiming and
suddenly i mean we were just really fast
friends
um yeah and then he decided to sing on
the song and i was like oh no i hope
this sounds good
because i'm like shoot and it did i mean
he sounds
he sounds like butter it's the best
i like butter i like that it's so good
but obviously you're
you've had success but i mean to get
into that
world of nile like the whole one
direction world like the fandom you must
have just seen
an explosion in terms of on your social
media right when that came out like
what's that like to all of a sudden
that be happening oh man
well i don't this is a loaded question
man oh okay
i don't know no it's good i i
again i think i didn't expect
this sort of level of um
adoption or like they like his fan base
and the one direction fan base
truly like adopted me into their world
um and based on
you know there's not a lot of other
like women that that fan base like
typically latches
on to so and there was no sense in my
mind i was like cool
they'll listen to the song but they're
not gonna they're not gonna
be my fans too and then suddenly i mean
within
like a week or two i was like this is
this is really happening
like holy smokes they were like
she's the sixth member of one direction
and i'm like oh yeah
what you guys look crazy
yeah silly so what do you learn from
experiences with other artists like nyle
like phineas as you work with as well
like what do you learn from working with
people like that
oh they're the best to work with because
they've been
in it for so long and been successful
for for so long well finn and i have
been in it around the same amount of
time but he's been
wildly more successful so he has much
more to tell me
um obviously with billy eilish i've
learned
um a lot from him um but that's the
thing
with with niall and phineas and people
like them that i've worked with
they have so much wisdom um
and are really good at like i kind of
said earlier detaching themselves
from the result you know and reminding
reminding ourselves that we're here for
the music
and that has to matter then it has to
matter the most
um because if anything else matters more
than
the music i mean you're going to set
yourself up for
a real crash and burn
yeah i've learned that from them for
sure some new songs save myself
i would use the word devastating again
ash
are you happy that's what i want to know
are you happy ash you seem very happy
but these songs are
rip your heart out oh man well i think i
think i'm
a lot of different a lot just like
anybody there's a lot of different faces
and and
parts to us i definitely let my
emotional side out the most
when i'm writing and then the side that
people see in interviews
is typically more bubbly and you know
just i'm hanging out with a friend you
know so it's a different
it's like a different i tap into a
different part of me
you know when i'm writing music and um i
genuinely
am a pretty happy person i will say that
um
so don't be worried by my music but okay
good
is this the same relationship about the
same relationship
yeah okay yeah yeah there's gonna be a
few more records that are right
you got you got like a lifetime of songs
out of
a breakup that big but um
but that's that i am writing about a lot
of other things as well so
i know you're very happy with spencer i
know that
you know spence i love he loves spencer
yeah and he's so uh he's so wonderful
like how does he feel about like you
writing all these just devastating songs
about a past
relationship like is that weird for him
you know what i i've gotten that
question a lot
and frankly i i didn't even think about
it and
and we didn't really have the
conversation and then someone asked me
and i was like
babe is this like an issue for you are
you good like
does this bother you at all and he was
like no
like you were married like you were
married like on our very first date i
was very transparent about
my life and my past and what i do for a
career um
it's a very public life and i talk about
my life and
so i don't he's just like the least
um jealous human just the most down to
earth and he's just
also i think when someone is so solid in
themselves
yeah do whatever you need to do
yeah he's been yeah he's just the most
supportive
so for people that don't know your music
how would you describe your sound
that's that's like the hardest is it yes
i would describe it as musical um
i don't know it's good yeah it's good
start it's
very musical um i don't
know i mean it's definitely pretty weird
i mean definitely i mean i write pop
i write pop records but they're
i would say like the singer-songwriter
singer-songwriter pop i don't know
i could ask this question too many times
to not know that
yeah well people just need to listen
yeah yeah i just want you to decide for
yourselves
yeah i'm what i'm realizing is a lot of
kids are showing their parents and their
parents are liking
the music too so there seems like
there's a little
generational like um bridge
so i don't know maybe it's a gender
a multi-generational pop
music for the whole family because